[Music]
get the g
fuel nice and center oh
i'm excited very epic christmas edition
of
the y did you have a good christmas i
missed you guys
i had a great christmas yes and no
actually
let's just say my dogs had a great
christmas because they ate all the candy
but i'm excited to be back i got a new
sweater now what's that about
what what i left pewdiepie channel for
two days and now i can't keep up anymore
exciting announcement at the end of this
video stay tuned
but let's get into memes
[Music]
in the next episode this was posted a
year
ago guys i grew into it yes
that's so awesome damn he went from 1919
real fast god damn
it's actually real it happens that's
amazing upload
[ __ ] i forgot about lizzie lava i
supposed to call him is he online
it just hit me there he is oh my god
he's literally there now what me waiting
for felix to reach out to me
bro i forgot shh it was christmas okay i
apologize
maybe he'll jump on later okay you meet
a girl she's cute and she seems into you
she watches pewdiepie she goes to you
you realize you can confront her by
getting into hawaii
ps what the frick cake okay
give a guy a chance reply to his
messages
he's got big people like you want to
respond trust me
the y has just become i don't even know
what this is anymore
a lot of people don't know this but you
can turn what
oh my god i gotta try this that's
amazing i've been doing it all wrong
i was a veteran and i didn't even know
that yeah that was crazy
so i'm going to edit pewdiepie's 10 hour
long recording into a 20-minute vlog
video oh
no he doesn't have to do that i'll i'll
leave it uncut we literally just did
landscaping for three hours i don't know
why
anyone watch hey
appreciate your time honestly well done
i'm really i'm always proud to say he's
a great it's a great editor
people at age 30 then let's have kids
okay people at age 30 now no pasta for
you
stop you're giving me a mid-life crisis
stop it
guys i'm not trying to milk it i hope
someone else is post and i'll put a line
next just
come up bunny all right life advice for
bunny
uh no and you know what bunny we're
gonna have to see something else for a
lie
take what i learned taught you in
minecraft and show me
i need to see it felix avoiding
controversies this year oh
oh god damn oh hell yeah
oh oh oh
[Laughter]
controversies in utah apparently yeah
that's right
thumbs up smash like on this video no
controversies this year
i can avoid making jokes
it's not a big deal it doesn't matter
doesn't affect me it sucks that [ __ ]
sucks i have to question every single
goddamn thing that comes out of my mouth
now
are they gonna get it are they gonna
understand that that was a joke
[Music]
sorry i didn't edit that joke app though
we don't have jokes anymore
you can't make jokes anymore guys you
all know this kids didn't marry when i
say in 2019 because it was the
perfect time to do it he did it in that
year
because then 50th wedding anniversary
will be in 2069.
and that's that's your typical reddit
post right there well done guys are we
still doing the six
months yeah six
nine
wow that's so cool 50 years
maybe maybe then by then the six nine
joke will be funny again who knows
i don't know he was asking someone to
co-host meme review
yeah that seems about right
it's an honor and a privilege we have
blue shirt kid
we have jacksepticeye who's next
who's next that's all i want to know
who's next aoc
huh so people can stop being mad about
ben shapiro
we're politically neutral here guys yeah
we have no opinions at all does your
chair do this
actually it
the [ __ ] oh great 2020 just got worse i
can't even
see how fast that was they fixed the
chair so i can't do the meme where it
falls back anymore
it's impossible can i i'm scared dude
i'm too stable hold up there we go
that's a weak spot
oh yeah well can you go under your table
god damn uncomfortable yeah all right
max yeah here's making fun of italians
peeps getting no pass
i got pasta for lunch thank you very
much [ __ ]
actually it was ravioli
father-in-law is a huge pewdiepie fan
what so we got him
they're under melee chair
hell yeah my man it lights
up just wait until he sees it lifts up
it's so it took two of us to carry it up
the stairs
my man's officially floor gang oh i
thought that was a tambourine now that's
a laundry
basket okay so hang on so there's
there's a lot of controls
yeah okay there's a
lever on your right hand like a but not
like the lower level like on the chair
yeah
it's right here an airplane seat or
something yeah that goes back
so it locks into place yeah
i'm not sure it's supposed to go that
far back the table safe it is supposed
to go this far
that's mess that's wholesome as hell
that's amazing
[Laughter]
those bastards lie to me you got less up
buds
oh no oh that's small bp sorry you have
tiny pp
you can't defeat me negligible i know
but he can't what the [ __ ] eligibility
now i know how to do it eligibility
eligibility
bro any word any word
oh eligibility [ __ ]
not problem animal crossing christmas
special
no one cares with marzia oh
god it was the deal she comes back to
animal crossing
i get pasta pete's naming characters in
minecraft series
common swedish name or incredibly dumb
name that eventually becomes funny
they were never funny but god damn i do
miss peepee poopoo
mom can we have pewdiepie no we have
pewdiepie at home pewdiepie at home
oh come on man looks good everyone said
that was so cringy i
i mean it's better than the normal
rewinds i don't know at least we got
something we're waiting for mr b still
how many controversies have you had this
year
pewdiepie yeah yeah
zero zero zero i don't make jokes
anymore that's all you gotta do
[Music]
this is another troll
i think i know where this is going
[Laughter]
to reverse a five-year-old oh my god
guys
there's too much pressure having
five-year-olds watching me please don't
don't let your five-year-olds watching
me please they don't know
that adam warlock 707 got popular
because of my meme
oh i didn't know that shanna the lear b
well you know what you deserve respect
as well
this [ __ ] reddit has got some meta
hey
[Music]
[Applause]
i didn't know that i honestly didn't
know then a lot of people don't know
this you could kill the wither with bees
i actually knew that
and what do you think i was doing this
whole time come on we're gonna grow an
army of
it will literally become dubstep my
swedish grandpa
tried lingenberry g fuel for the first
time tis the drink of the season is it
everyone always complain i have i don't
i had too much g fuel okay
but it makes it taste so much better i
like a lot of flavor what can i say
is like this that's enough that's enough
they they do
he does look swedish doesn't he they
must be sweetie
okay so am i on video here yeah
so my spencer boyka he gives me the
pewdiepie lingenberry
let's see what happens to poor grandpa
grandpa's gonna rock it off that chair
hey hey what was that
so as we say in swedish good for
that means god forsaken devil
why did he say it in swinglish
good for banana yeah well he put it in
english that's so funny good for banana
oh man that means god forsaken them you
know it means it was the best one ever
code pewdiepie check it out grandpa prus
that's what that means in swedish
[Laughter]
what a merry christmas i love that she's
probably busy making pasta
marcia and i took that personally
you see this can she hear i just
realized
there's someone eating pasta right there
oh my god
crazy coincidence six nine
what did you do during lockdown dead i
stayed at home and made ten furnaces in
minecraft hardcore mode
[ __ ] legend [ __ ] legend right
there
i can't believe i haven't died yet if i
haven't died before the end of the year
where i'm going to do a long live stream
until i die so basically i did some
off-camera building
yeah so i did the live stream when i did
all the boring stuff when i was building
and landscaping everyone's like
this is so boring he doesn't do anything
what do you want from me
god damn
accidentally breaks blocking his house
no
for those who didn't have time to watch
the livestream we built the home for
and we finally got the honey block it
was a legendary
they don't know i thought beats to say
negligible
it was legitimate focus thank you teach
me more stuff guys
i need to learn i'm sick of being a half
idiot have full idiot okay i'm a man who
owns
five ovens
[Music]
can we take a moment to remember the old
pictures let's just take a moment
okay we're done thank you all right to
spice it up a bit
the next top voted lawyer picture
will be my next profile picture with the
with the thing
can be fan art can be meme whatever it
is top loaded
i'll use it any time periods finds
younglings in the nether child
don't run master skywalker
there are too many of them what are we
going to do
i just watched it yes give me your life
just so we're clear i feel very
uncomfortable when i do it i do it as a
joke
okay it's very clear i'm not saying this
i just want you to know i i feel even in
minecraft it feels weird
but it's funny what the [ __ ] is this
stop he's gonna go to open lane
hey oh you did you did it
the thing is i appreciate the meme
but like i wanted to do the sepsis
episode but you guys are so much ahead
of me how am i gonna keep up with this
pewdiepie in the nether pewdiepie with
pewdiepie with jurgen pewdiepie in
villages
yeah that's actually accurate how about
that a spongebob meme
flipping the meme so it makes sense
from pewds me
[Music]
okay can you see it are you happy are
you satisfied
hold up and hands and hands and hands
i stoop right ah
enhance there it is
yeah yeah don't look ignore the baby cap
oh god they swing their back
oh god damn it
quote from today's minecraft live stream
i don't like beat sabers the songs are
so sh
yeah you have to mod it come on come on
i don't know why i don't like it
i don't know i'm sorry i beat saber fans
i don't know i think it's cringey i'm
gonna say it
y'all cringe at my awkwardness yeah i
cringe at you like in beat saber
yeah two can play that game oh my god
this meme is still going
it can't okay it can't what do you want
from me god damn it
clutch fix the chairs we need it needs
to break people's backs
he's working right now god damn it he's
working so he can buy more gpu
oh that's amazing is that real god damn
oh a little ag a gpg
edgy pidgey pattern uh finland no one
cares about finland
me a finn who keeps hearing insults
towards my country for my favorite
internet person
oh now i feel bad don't it's it see i
can't make jokes
damn it uh never been to finland
but mimi trollit love it
uh the fairies that goes between
sweden finland i love them finnish
inventions
all right let's see what you got yo they
made the dish training closet
what i'm feeling the best
oh they made the heart rate man that's
like yeah sure
the internet browser look how happy they
are about it
like this these are the most finished
looking dudes i have ever seen get it
finished
because they look done i can make jokes
no
[ __ ] i wasn't supposed to god damn it
wind turbine
oh i dissed wind turbine in that
livestream i said we need to cancel wind
ah scissors
they made [ __ ] sauna of course i'm
also
all right finland you're all right i
apologize
guys i am so sorry about soundness
nokia of course of course oh they made
linux that's sick actually that's
probably their biggest invention then
texting get the [ __ ] out of here nah
they didn't do that that's a lie
finnish lies that's what they do they
try to get your sympathy and then they
fill you with lice i know
i'm not listening to anything you have
oh my god pewdiepie
beating my work is coca-belly yeah this
diss
track is gonna it's gonna change
everyone's gonna want to get on board
after i make the same joke twice guys
it's gonna
[ __ ] oh
she loves pewdiepie oh now i can't kill
any more kittens
damn it i also want to announce guys
big news number one tc
chandler the biggest authority of
handsome faces
put your boy that
photo yeah yeah
yeah hall of fame youtuber
minecrafter merch vlogger
yes yes we finally did it
yes number one baby
all right that's amazing who did we beat
manna
oh god damn it oh he looks swedish he's
canadian
alexandro i am sorry not good enough
not good enough chris pine more like
chris
no spine that's the shittiest joke i've
ever made okay
patrick's i can't say that okay got that
that was close hyeong jane
come on julie oh hey hey k-pop stands
okay i get it all right i'm not number
one
let me just have this please god damn it
i get it i appreciate it it's easy
channel there i feel like chevrolet guy
looks a lot like pewdiepie let's see
everyone rip me in the comments
i'm scared of looking here let's go what
what i'll thumb up a comment i don't
care
let's go yeah
all right you guys are in there what the
[ __ ] i expect it to be rip apart
let's go
amazing guys it's been my pleasure this
week aloy
don't mess up next episode because we
got lester lava coming on hell yeah
oh wait what is this oh hell yeah new
more appropriate body hell yeah
hey new year's coming up you know what
that means lift
lift did my camera froze oh god when did
it freeze
when it ah i'm profiting the screen
right now
imagine the brofist